from a sudden car accident to a
disgraced Hollywood producer there are
several shocking reasons why Kill Bill
vol 3 never materialized and why there's
a good chance it never will Kill Bill
vol 1 is the only one of Quentin
Tarantino's movies to get a sequel so
why hasn't it received a three quote if
you're looking for a simple answer it
said Tarantino is waiting for his stars
to grow up a bit from the very beginning
Tarantino has said that his plan for a
potential volume 3 requires the actors
from the original films to be at least
15 years older not just the adults like
Uma Thurman and Daryl Hannah but also
child actors Perla Haney Jardine and
Ambrosia Kelly the longer and more
complicated answers that Tarantino style
has evolved over the last two decades
and the projects he's made more recently
look very different from Kill Bill Death
Proof part of the 2007 double feature
experiment Grindhouse was the last of
his films to have a certain Kill Bill
Vibe mostly due to the performance of
Thurman's stunt double Zoe Bell as a
fictionalized version of herself from
2009 onward however he moved forward
with a very different series of Revenge
films rewriting historical atrocities
with Inglorious Bastards Django and
Chained and Once Upon a Time in
Hollywood a focus on the literary rather
than the Visionary has consumed
Tarantino's output in the last decade
from the drawing room drama of the
hateful eight to his novelization of
Once Upon a Time in Hollywood as his
self-imposed career clock is ticking
down it seems a strong possibility that
another Kill Bill sequel just isn't
something that interests Tarantino very
much anymore journalists have been
asking Quentin Tarantino about a
possible volume 3 for two decades and
the famously Gabby director has happily
obliged and gleefully fueled the rumors
in 2004 he referred to the possible
series as his take on Sergio Leone's
dollars Trilogy and claimed that his
initial plan was to make a sequel every
10 years once 10 years had actually
passed though things had changed while
promoting the hateful eight in 2015
Tarantino told variety I'm not
committing to it but I wouldn't be
surprised if the Bride made one more
appearance before the whole thing is
said and done Tarantino has also
repeatedly stated that he will direct
only 10 films once he completes that
10th and final film he will apparently
retire from making movies with every new
release in the last few years he's
gotten closer to that self-imposed cut
off and unless he breaks his vow or
finds a loophole it looks less and less
likely that Kill Bill vol 3 will be
included in this filmography the Kill
Bill films are all about revenge and
they center around an important ethical
question is a desire to seek retribution
finish unfinished business ever
Justified or merely a justification
Beatrix kiddo sets out to destroy the
people who destroyed her life but she
kills an awful lot of other people along
the way Bill even calls her out on it
during their final confrontation lspp
you chill to get to me
felt damn good didn't they
the bride sliced through dozens of Oren
ishee's bodyguards not for some
high-minded active Cosmic balance but
because she enjoyed doing it according
to Tarantino a third film would pick up
the Revenge theme for a new generation
Nikki Bell daughter of former deadly
Viper assassination Squad member vernita
green seeks revenge against the bride
for the death of her mother raised and
trained by the treacherous Sophie fatal
whom Beatrix left maimed but alive Nikki
would set out for her own righteous
Vengeance facing the bride along with
her now grown daughter Bibi kiddo you
can take my word for it
your mother had it coming back in 2007
series producer E Bennett Walsh told the
audience at the Shanghai Film Festival
that the third and potentially fourth
film might also feature a pair of former
henchmen from the first movie seeking
their own revenge against the bride the
first two Kill Bill films leave precious
few characters Alive by the end but
there are a few actors that would be
expected to return in a follow-up first
and foremost of course is Beatrix kiddo
herself Uma Thurman Julie Dreyfus could
also return as Sophia fatal as well as
Daryl Hannah as the bride's Nemesis
Ellie driver what blinded but alive at
the end of Kill Bill vol 2. several
actors from the films have sadly died in
the last two decades including David
Carradine and sunny Chiba the real
question is who would play the now grown
BB and Nikki Part of Quentin Tarantino's
plan to wait 15 years was to give actor
Ambrosia Kelly time to grow up in 2004
he told Entertainment Weekly it's
exciting to know that somewhere there's
a little girl who will grow up to be my
Leading Lady however Kelly hasn't acted
on screen since 2012 and in 2023 Vivica
A fox said in interview with variety
that are dream casting for the role of
Nikki would be Zendaya as for Bibi Perla
Haney Jardine remains active in the
business and even had a small role in
Once Upon a Time in Hollywood in recent
years though a different candidate has
emerged therma's real-life daughter Maya
Hawk who's become a star in her own
right Quentin Tarantino has developed a
routine company of sorts over the years
and for a while Uma Thurman was not just
a company player but a muse and
collaborator of the director the two of
them developed the character of the
Bride while working together on Pulp
Fiction after all the deadly Viper
assassination Squad sounds an awful lot
like the crime fighting team and Mia
Wallace's TV pilot Fox Force 5. fox is
in where a bunch of Foxy chicks Force as
in were forced to be reckoned with and
fives in this one two three four five of
us however Thurman and Tarantino have
not worked together since Kill Bill Vol
2 came out in 2004 and more than a
decade later one of the possible reasons
why came to light in a 2018 profile in
the New York Times Thurman stated that
Tarantino had coerced her into doing an
unauthorized automobile stunt instructed
to drive a conver convertible down a
whining path in Mexico at 40 miles per
hour Thurman lost control of the car and
ran off the side of the road resulting
in a concussion and damage to her knees
footage of the accident was released
online after the story dropped footage
which according to Thurman Tarantino had
fought for years to keep private in an
Instagram post accompanying the profile
Thurman acknowledged that Tarantino
finally allowed her to release the
footage and said that it feels
remorseful about the incident even after
making amends personally the two have
yet to collaborate again in the
Instagram post featuring footage of Uma
Thurman's rack she wrote that while she
feels the negligent stunt itself was not
done with malicious intent the 15-year
cover-up of the accident very much was
an act of malice Thurman laid the blame
not at Quentin Tarantino but squarely at
the Peter producers Lawrence Bender E
Bennett Walsh and Harvey Weinstein that
wasn't the only thing she accused
Weinstein of either in the 2018 New York
Times profile Thurman claimed that
Weinstein sexually assaulted her on two
different occasions in the 90s and he
threatened to end her career when she
confronted him over his actions she
wasn't the only one as other
high-profile stars like Mira Vino and
Selma Hayek also shared their harrowing
stories with a powerful producer
Weinstein ran the Disney Affiliated
Indie distributor Miramax and not only
produced both Kill Bill movies but
championed and nurtured Tarantino's
career from the very beginning in return
Tarantino's Works helped turn Miramax
and Weinstein himself into a Hollywood
Power Player on a household name
Tarantino worked with Weinstein on every
one of his films from Reservoir Dogs to
the hateful eights in 2015. and even
though he has since distanced himself
from the disgraced executive their
longtime friendship casts a shadow over
much of Tarantino's work Kill Bill vol 3
isn't the only long-awaited Kill Bill
project that may never see the light of
day the official narrative from Miramax
and Quentin Tarantino has always been
that the two Kill Bill films were
originally intended to be a single
four-hour movie but it was split into
two volumes in order to improve its
chances at the box office that may or
may not be true after all the two films
are very different from each other in
style and other than Uma Thurman they
have largely different casts the idea
that they were ever meant to form one
coherent film is slightly dubious but
nevertheless Tarantino has dangled the
possibility of a combined feature called
the whole bloody Affair for years as of
2023 there have only been two confirmed
public screenings of the whole bloody
Affair one was at the Cannes Film
Festival in 2004 and the other was a
two-week run in 2011 at the New Beverly
Cinema the Los Angeles theater owned by
Tarantino reports from those screenings
confirmed that the combined feature runs
mostly the same as what the rest of the
world already saw but with a few
differences the epic fight between the
bride and the Crazy 88 gang is presented
entirely in color and certain key scenes
and lines have been cut despite these
tantalizing details there appear to be
no plans to release it publicly again in
theaters or on Blu-ray and streaming in
March 2023 Quentin Tarantino announced
his next film the movie critic 70 set
drama abouts you guessed it a movie
critic when the movie critic comes out
it will be Tarantino's 10th film and his
film career is supposedly finished after
that if the director follows through
that means lights out for Kill Bill vol
3. Tarantino reinforced this idea in
July 2023 while doing an interview with
the Flemish newspaper de Morgan when
asked if Maya Hawk could play the
bride's daughter in a third Kill Bill
film The auteur replied I don't see that
my last film was about a film critic a
male critic and he plays in the 70s if
you're looking for the last word on the
subject that seems pretty final however
don't give up all hope just yet Azuma
Thurman raised an intriguing possibility
when she was asked about it in 2022 she
told Fox 5 New York all I know is he's
always said he's going to make 10 but it
doesn't include if he does television
could vol 3 show up as a streaming
series at some point like Tarantino's
expansion of the hateful eight for
Netflix in 2019 we'll just have to wait
and see whether or not he's decided to
pull a little trick on his fans
silly rap
tricks are for kids
even though rumors have circulated since
2004 it's been years since Kill Bill vol
3 has had any significant movement maybe
we actually will see it on the bigger
small screen at some point with aged up
Stars Perla Haney Jardine and Ambrosia
Kelly or maybe Maya Hawk and Zendaya and
each other's throats only time will tell
at this point but if the project never
comes to pass it will at least be in
good company Tarantino seems to enjoy
talking about films he will never make
as much as actually making films and the
last three decades are littered with
would-be features that never grew Beyond
his imagination for every Inglorious
Bastards there's a double v Vega which
would have brought together John
Travolta and Michael Madsen as their
well-dressed Pulp Fiction and Reservoir
Dogs characters for every once upon a
time in Hollywood there is a 60 set
Casino Royale or an R-rated Star Trek
sequel that Sparks speculation and
excitement before fizzling and fading
away as he goes in a New Direction Kill
Bill vol 3 may only ever exist in our
imaginations but if it does happen
Against All Odds we know it'll be a
bloody good time